This episode of Dnews is brought to you by
Ting: Mobile that Makes Sense.
More and more states are banning cellphone
use while driving - but is it actually effective?
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and since
2008, California has had a ban on all hand-held
cellphone use while driving.
Previous studies using driving simulators,
have found that people who talk on a cellphone
while driving - are equally as impaired as
people driving while intoxicated. Although
none of those studies have been conducted
on actual drivers - so it’s possible the
statistics change when someone gets behind
the wheel.
In any case, a new study from the University
of Colorado Boulder, shows that the ban in
California has been largely ineffective - and
there’s been no decrease in traffic accidents
since the law was put into place.
Researchers looked at the rates of accidents
in California for the 6 months leading up
to the ban, and compared it to the number
of accidents in the 6-month period after.
They chose that relatively small window of
time, so they could avoid confounding variables
that might impact their numbers, like the
introduction of safer cars on the road, or
the reduction in the number of drivers, due
to things like economic recession and rising
gas prices. They also accounted for precipitation
levels - which are known to increase accident
rates.
The purpose of the study was to see if the
ban was effective, but the fact that it’s
not - raises a lot of questions about why
that may be.
According to the author of the study, Dr.
Daniel Kaffine, there are several possible
reasons. The most obvious one, would be that
people simply aren’t complying with the
law - although similar bans have been enacted
in other states, and they seem to be effective
there. If this is really the reason, then
logic dictates that increasing the fines associated
with the ban - at least in California - could
produce better results.
Another possible theory, is that hands-free
devices - which are still allowed under the
law - could be just as distracting as handheld
cell phones. And there are studies out there
that corroborate that.
It’s also possible that the type of people
who drive recklessly with cellphones - are
just prone to distracted driving, no matter
what. So even if they’re not using their
cell phones - they could be fiddling with
other things, like the radio or a GPS device.
Kaffine says that more research needs to be
done to figure out why the number of traffic
accidents hasn’t decreased since the ban
was put into place - and that doing so - could
lead to more effective policies in the future.
I think it’s safe to say that as long as
you’re not using them while driving, cellphones
are a pretty awesome invention. But you know
what’s not awesome? Paying your monthly
cellphone bill. It’s expensive, it’s confusing
- So what if there was a better way?
Well with Ting, there absolutely is. Ting
is a new mobile phone service that puts the
power back in your hands. There are no plans,
no cancellation fees, and best of all - no
hidden fees or charges! With Ting, you ONLY
pay for the data you actually use - and you
can leave whenever you like!
Their bills are easy to understand, and completely
transparent - and 98% of customers who switch
to Ting - actually save money on their monthly
cell phone bills.
Head over to dnews.ting.com and click on their
Savings Calculator - to see how much money
Ting could save YOU over a 2-year period.
Again that’s dnews.ting.com, and remember
- every visit to that link helps support show.
In the meantime, let us know what YOU think
of this study - and if you live in a state
that’s banned handheld cellphone while driving
- do you still use it? Leave your responses
in the comments below, and as always - thank
you guys for watching!